I think we should have a spin-off Series
where Janelle and my mom get together
wait what
I think we should have a spin-off Series
where Janelle and my mom get together
yeah Sister Wives star Gwendolyn Brown
wants her mom Christine and her former
sister wife Janelle to date I'm super
close with Janelle that's that's of
course very different uh just Janelle
and I are to probably just continue the
21 year old whom Christine shares with
her ex-husband Cody Brown drops her idea
in a new YouTube reaction video of the
TLC series revealing she totally ships
her mom and Janelle together I think we
should have a spin-off Series where
Janelle and my mom get together
tell me you don't love that idea Sister
Wives
what should be called Sister Wives I
don't know wives of course the ladies
are both now single Christine split from
Cody in late 2021. so for us plural
merge doesn't work
for us marriage doesn't work I would say
it's so much better I think just because
I'm so more grounded and I just like my
I just like me and I like my life so
much better now while Janelle's
currently separated from the Brown
family patriarch after nearly 30 years
of what they called spiritual marriage
Cody and I have separated and I'm happy
really happy she's like yeah you know I
haven't missed you much
but when it comes to Gwen's idea of
Christine and Janelle dating that might
be a little far-fetched
tell me you don't love that idea the
thought of a spin-off though now that's
something Christine is totally down for
oh that'd be fun I don't know as far as
the spin-off dude I'm totally open no I
do what it looks like but absolutely
that'd be just fun as heck and as far as
Sister Wives goes Christine told E.T
she's not going anywhere I made like a
promise to like Cody and everybody else
and I will stay with Sister Wives as
long as we have the show just to be fair
it's what our family's been doing for so
long and so no I absolutely I feel like
it would be disloyal if I you know
decided to not be part of the show and
even though she's disassociated from the
family and moved away back to Utah
Christine says we'll still see her
filming with her closest former sister
wife Janelle and her kids I am still
with them so as far as Sister Wives go
I'll still be doing things with Janelle
quite regularly
foreign
[Music]